MONTREAL GAME.
I THOUGHT THEY DID AN ACCEPTABLE
TORONTO DEFENSEMAN.
IT'S QUICKLY DUMPS RIGIG FACE-O.
IT IS ROSLOVIC SNAPPING IT BACK.
RIGHT AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
SHSH
LESS THAN A MINUTE LEFT IN THE
POWER PLAY.
IME SHOT COMES
COME SLOWLY TOWARDS HIM. DID THH
THE EXPERIENCE IN THE
HOCKEY LEAEA
AND NOW BACK
>> Jody: HE'S WON THEM BOTH. TO.
COMES RIGHT INSHOOTS AND SCORES!
PATRIK LAINE HAS NOT ENDEDNG PAO
ANOTHER SHOT.
WE ARE TIED UP THIS SAVE OFRE.
YOU SEE HOW HEE HERE.
>> GOOD JOB THERE, THEY
TIMES TEAMS THE POINT.
A SHOT OFF THE BLOCKER. MANHANDR
WITH SOME RESPONSE.
A THIS THIRD PERIOD. JUST SHOWSS
SPEED AS THEIR NEWEST TO NET.
THE RIGHT
MO
IN.Jeff: 38 SAVES.
WAS IT IDEA
IDEAS.
>> Jeff: LEADING 8 OF 9.